كانت الحلول الأمنية في السفر
متنوعة مثل الوجهات المختلفة
وأنواع الأشخاص الذين يسافرون. جيسي
أشلوك هي الولايات المتحدة.  رئيس تحرير Conde Nast
الذي التقينا به في نيويورك ،
وهو يقود النسخة الأمريكية من
مجلة السفر العالمية التي يقول إن
هناك اتجاهات جديدة تلوح في الأفق في عام 2019
، تم دمج إصدارات الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة من Conde Nast Traveler
تحت قيادة عالمية واحدة مقرها في
لندن بالمملكة المتحدة في الولايات المتحدة.  لقد نجحت في سد ثلاثة
آلاف ونصف من الأميال من
المحيط الأطلسي ، ما كان الهدف
هو أن السفر هو اتجاه عالمي بطبيعته
صناعة عالمية وأردنا تجميع
مواردنا لنصبح علامة تجارية عالمية حقًا
للسفر وهذا يعني جلب
الخبرة البريطانية والطلاقة مع السوق الأوروبية
ودمجها مع
الخبرة الأمريكية في الطلاقة مع
سوق أمريكا الشمالية لتصبح
أكثر توحيدًا في تفكيرنا حول ما
يعنيه السفر اليوم حتى نتمكن من
القضاء على بعض أوجه القصور
والتكرار والتحدث مع
جمهورنا بقدر أكبر بكثير مما
تراه  نظرًا لكونه نوعًا من الاتجاهات التي
تراها الآن من خلال قرائك
، أعتقد بالتأكيد أن الاتجاه
نحو السفر الصحي
ينمو وينمو وينمو وينمو
ويعكس الاحتضان الأكبر للعافية
كجزء من حياتنا ونوع
الاهتمام  في اليقظة ، يتحدث الجميع
عن التجربة ،
يبدو أن التجربة قد تغيرت
منذ 15 عامًا  لقد كان منطادًا من الهواء الساخن
فوق الصحراء اليوم ، إنه شيء أكثر
شمولية لأمها أعتقد
بشكل متزايد أنه يعني القيام بشيء
لا يفعله أي شخص آخر لدرجة أن كوني
تعرف أن المسافر قد حددنا مجموعة
من الأشخاص أطلقنا عليها اسم
nilam الجديد  نظرًا لوجود أشخاص يسافرون
للعمل ولكن هناك أيضًا أشخاص
يسافرون بنفس الجدية
والمتعمد لقضاء وقت الفراغ وضمن
ذلك هناك مجموعة فرعية نعتقد أنها
تمثل حوالي 7٪ من الجمهور الأمريكي
الذي نطلق عليه اسم
المسافر الدائم وهم  دائمًا ما يكونون دائمًا في
وضع السفر إذا كانوا لا يسافرون إلى
مكان ما ، فهم يحجزون رحلة في الوقت
الحالي ، فهم دائمًا ما يكونون دائمًا في
لحظة السفر حتى عندما يكونون في
المنزل ونراهم نوعًا ما مثل
رواد الأعمال للمسافرين  بشكل عام ،
لكنهم دائمًا ما يكونون مسافرون ، ما هي كل
خصائصهم التي يعرفون عن
الأماكن قبل أن يمر أي شخص آخر
بتجارب لم يكن لدى أي شخص آخر
ما نتحدث عنه من قبل وأن يكون
قادرًا على ذلك  نوعًا ما تخدم
كمنسق غير رسمي لمجتمع من
الأصدقاء ، وأعتقد
أن المسافر الدائم مثلنا نوعًا ما
لأن المسافرين يرون شيئًا من
أنفسنا في المسافر الدائم ، فهم
يمثلون صوتًا للسلطة الاجتماعية الخاصة بهم
ضع دائرة
حولك